was never great we found it on the rape
in the murder
nothing changed so we setting up our own
response to these situations that we
dealing with people get shot every other
day kids get shot people kill each other
black people kill each other there was
just no way that people are gonna just
sit back and allow children to be shot
down by law enforcement this country
doesn't work for us it doesn't function
for us
this is can't be happening in America
Michael Brown say his name everybody one
betta for you man just shouldn't be
a lot of people are fighting for you
three years since your past man we miss
you we love you
you sit off a revolution for this whole
country for this whole world man
the thing about my crown was before that
it had been several decades since
America had had an uprising like that
you know and we kind of missed our
opportunity I feel like with the
Ferguson situation
sir I appreciate you fighting for our
rights sir thank you for fighting for
our right for real thank you
the state isn't for us this country
doesn't work for us it doesn't function
for us
you can't talk with a machine that's a
machine so you can't have any real
conversation about real life and
feelings and what people are going
through with a machine with a robot
you can only destroy a robot it's got to
be taken down and abolished because when
they've made the Constitution and all
this but it really wasn't made for me
white people didn't want to live next to
black people and so it created some
suburbs and small little towns there's
like Ferguson floors and these small
little towns existed you'll tell by the
flats and there's a lot of homes so they
just stack poor people just back-to-back
on top of each other
I live in the hood which is like
probably like one of the roughest parts
in the state at least don't come too
often people get shot every other day
kids get shot people kill each other
black people kill each other I always
had a gun I had something on always
drug-related same on story
black people have always been a target
dan says he was a cool dude you know he
was serious
he loved black people he loved his
people is enough to sacrifice and so he
started to organize people started to
start his own organization to actually
try to fight some of these things these
heels could have been world known
that the police weren't allowed
poverty creates crime that's anywhere
you get rid of poverty you get rid of
crime simple is that simple people
applaud here this is one of the lowest
minimum wages in the country constant
police harassment the drug epidemic like
it's a lot of different factors that
you're dealing with heard that white
supremacy benefits from that the
capitalistic government benefits from
and we sit here and we starve it so
people look at us they think are they
just savages or the animals or they had
they don't want to do better it's not
that we don't have an opportunity to do
better
is it safe to go here and film depends
on your belief of God doesn't it
can something bad happen to us here that
very possibility there's no guarantees
in life is her st. Louis has probably
more abandoned houses than any other
city in America its size people with
children they you know they moved to the
county they moved to suburbs for better
schools and for safer streets and all
that kind of stuff
hey what's that man I was looking for
you there's some water
how you doing that'll keep you fit that
will keep you fit just grab your bang
coming get you - yeah when we got other
stuff just good - two sandwiches yeah
there you go this is my pastor that's
right he's a pretty good gentleman
respect everything that he say and I try
to live by wage a wonderful one is that
vice to me is always good you know out
here sometimes you run the people that
you just really glad to see when you get
out here it's one of those kind of this
one of the brothers I'm just really glad
to see him
hey Joe Jim
I believe that anything that happens in
a person's life is not random that
there's a divine design behind it I
baptized a young man I was pastoring a
church in Webster Groves Missouri then I
baptized him at 14 I buried him at 17
and I had to do his funeral and watch
his mother and his grandmother whom I'm
very close to God started speaking to me
about the violence then and buried young
eulogized a young woman who was shot in
the head in broad daylight in a park in
front so there these things just kept
happening these young people just kept
dying who were in my sphere of influence
and I believed that God was speaking to
me about going into the streets then and
I decided then that it just made sense
for me to go out where the violence is
and interact and engage best way I could
and that's what we believe one person at
a time one street at a time one
neighborhood at a time
now people start killing each other so
after the death of my crown more people
were shot more people were robbed so
it's becoming more and more bad hearts
come to you this morning not in the name
of a movie or a movie or money come to
you
James Carney regarding everything's
become restive contango and Preston
templates when Robinson arrested him
Brian David Mackey
baby ray Davis why do he was executed he
was hanging around black kids and so in
America if you hang around they treat
you like it on that day he got the
treatment and black people
do you protect Hanna we want the
Department of Justice the st. Louis
Circuit attorney and a civilian
oversight board to investigate this
in the court today there's a police
officer X police officer named Jason
Hoppy jason Stockley and he's up for a
first-degree murder Stockley gets out
and fires four shots with the pistol
killing smith stock be twice returns to
the police vehicle to drop off an unused
rifle and to rummage do a duffel bag
Stockley was her saying during the
pursuit that he was going to kill Smith
but I think at the end of the day he's
not gonna get charged they're gonna let
him walk like they let everybody else
walk this man lost his life for meth and
that's why we've heard losses like
nothing we need justice to be here for
justice that's why we arm no to make
sure that that don't happen no more I do
think the revolution the real revolution
might happen soon
I think that'll happen sooner than like
another uprising in Ferguson oh I think
it's going is gonna look like a lot of
people dying it's come there's gonna be
a lot of bullets but for some people in
this country that's always been the
reality dying in bullets if we fight in
a real way beyond the signs in the
streets then yeah it'll change
you know I don't see his car so I don't
know I don't know where to leave it
anymore
he struggles with addiction
I met him right after his son was
murdered just a few blocks from here we
keep coming consistently and in time
we're able to build real trust and have
real relationships
most of the people out here are not bad
people there it's not a bad situation
not at all not at all
one night we had sort of been warned
about coming up here and and walking
that way so one night we were just
sitting up here resting and this dark
four-door might think Chevrolet pulled
up the windows were really really say a
tenant real dark and they just pulled up
on us real slow and I was sure that that
night we were gonna get shot live of the
shootings these days take place this
people are driving around the shootings
take place from cars hey what's up now
alright people now we've been doing this
for two years now man just come out here
pray for people pass our sandwiches give
our water thinking about thank you thank
you god bless you thank you all right
now
all right another thing I'm dangerous
here
so I don't really know what to expect
just to be honest with yourself now that
helicopter there is a police helicopter
we call it a ghetto bird
they're looking for somebody
we have what we call the the Delmar
divide where one part north of Delmar is
redlined
and neglected it's abused via neglect
and the other side you know you get all
the services and all the opportunities
that most white Americans enjoy
probably the scariest time was in the
first month that we started walking and
this young guy came out of a building
with a gun cursing me calling me all
kinds of snitches and everything and I
asked the group to go on ahead of me
because one of the rules is if anybody
gets shot it should be me several
gunshots rang out late Wednesday morning
in the 5400 block of South Kings Highway
one suspect was shot and killed by the
SWAT officers June 7th 2017 I got a
phone call for my father around 1054
that my son was dead that the cops
killed him my father said that my son
ran into his room and say grandpa would
get down stay down on the ground that
somebody's trying to break in my father
I asked who was shooting and my son said
I don't know grandpa I love you he
walked a couple steps inside by the
dining-room and said please don't shoot
please don't shoot
and then they ordered my son they began
to just keep shooting them
dudu was just a wonderful solo man it
was so strong like he had a relationship
with all of us more like like our
brother and we talked about things
beyond just just protested and
you know police brutality and he had a
lot of compassion and a lot of heart and
a lot of desires to do things greater
then you know just standing up for his
people standing up for his people and
also bringing them together and letting
us all cordless and build a greater
dream according to the autopsy he was
shot and he was birth organizations and
more than enough people had more than
enough motors for what happened to
during seals it's the hit list it's a
hit list with names and seals name was
on their hit list mine is on their hit
list several other people that was
involved in his movement name is on his
hit list we get daily threats from the
KKK and other white supremacist groups
we get threats from police law
enforcement government officials and we
also got to deal with the same
oppression here in our neighborhoods
because we come from the streets we got
to deal with rivals it's the reason I
have to ride like this it's a reason
it's a reason
then whose holy fate let us now
sincerely and reverently declare I
believe in God the Father Almighty make
up heaven and earth and in Jesus Christ
His only Son our Lord was conceived by
the Holy Ghost born of the Virgin Mary
suffered under Pontius Pilate was
crucified dead and buried the third day
he rose from the dead he ascended into
heaven and sitteth on the right hand of
God
you think you're now gone for those
persons that we encounter as we walk the
streets at night we pray God in the name
of Jesus you see sometimes in those
streets at I just want to scream and say
stop using drugs stop shooting each
other
stop drinking you're destroying your
life want to see that let's the hungry
and the hurting everywhere
bless this nation in the name of Jesus
I'm just throwing the word that I'm
fighting for my son I want answers and
I'm not gonna stop until I get them I
want the person who did it I want
answers why they came in and killed my
son the way they did they're supposed to
protect us but they're killing us
to us
it was the fact that we came drive down
the street without being harassed it was
the fact that we can't feed ourselves
because this is a food desert if there's
no money coming into the schools
no no materials these kids can't even
take books home for homework it's not
enough books for them to take books home
to do homework we can't get a job
because we black because this country is
built off a black oppression and black
pain that's what many people say you
know what we tired of this yeah yeah
world war we'll give you war your badge
or Police Department the government
we've won our freedom and we want it now
we not asking
you